we left here with rain on wednesday
night and we return to light showers
right now it's not raining very heavy so
they'll be able to get this game started
we'll have to see how long it remains
light and go from there well for perez
he's coming off a couple of really good
starts one against la
one against the philadelphia phillies
last time i got the win in the last two
games he's gone six innings in both of
those games the longest he's gone all
season and had a season high seven
strikeouts last time out against
philadelphia another 3-2
and he struck him out
perez gets out of a bind in the top of
the first
2-1 to alfaro
is hit in the air and hit well to deep
right field way
back and into the bullpen a two-run
homer for jorge alfaro
it is a long way out there to right at
fenway two-nothing miami
well pardon me mr alfaro you say an
incredible display of power i mean one
of the toughest right fields in the
american league as far as distance and
you know getting a ball out alfaro
goes the opposite way for a long two-run
home run to right
perez got a strikeout of cooper to end
the first trying to put away birdie here
in the second
2-2
strike three called
a backwards k to end the second
and rafi is first pitch swinging with
his cousin jose playing short he's in
the shift right now for the marlins
separated by three years both out of the
dominican
jose debra said this week they've never
played against each other but he was
excited for this
and he goes down swinging on 95 again
from poteet who is fan three and just
basically stayed with the fastball that
time when he got ahead of devins and put
him away with the strikeout
fastball up and away that's how a lot of
pitchers try to pitch devas when they
get ahead of him high fast balls away
from him and if he makes contact well
sometimes he'll pop it up or
sometimes he'll hit it hard off the wall
so the cousin wins that first battle
best ball in
2-2
and he got him
93 and that is paint from perez good job
by perez you know shows him something
outside and right back inside with the
fastball to pick up the strikeout
couldn't do much with that if he had
swung at him didn't expect it in there
he's looking away leaning out over the
plate
50 pitches in for martine
in his 10th start of the season
strike three calls three straight k's
now for perez yeah it looks like you
know cb buckman behind the plate is
calling him inside and outside tonight
and not up and down
that ball appeared to be inside but
strike three call by cb buckner and
surprising aguila but it might have been
a little makeup from the one that he
probably missed earlier
yeah on the change-up sounded like
aguilar on his way back was asking if it
if it hit the corner yeah so it's up to
jd martinez here in the third with the
red sox down a pair another 02 to him
and he pulls this one to left center
field back toward the wall and that'll
drive in two
renfro scores from second hernandez from
first and jd martinez ties the ball game
oh did he ever do a nice job staying
back on a change up that time and put a
charge in it off that left field wall
there's the off speed pitch to change up
it stays right about knee-high
and martinez absolutely crutches this
ball in the gap
it's a big two-out base hit here a
double i should say for martinez to tie
this one up at two
rbis number 38 and 39 for him on the
season
exit velo 108 that was stung by jd two
down for christian vasquez
vasquez drives this one deep to right
with cooper back spinning around and he
hangs on to it and they get a big smile
because they get the baseball a couple
of manhunts right there wow they're not
getting cheated out no i'm a baseball
baseball to abort here for verdugo
with one away in the fifth
and he pulls one to right sending cooper
back and that ball's gone
it's a three-run shot for alex ferdugo
and the red sox lead in the fifth
oh he didn't wait for that very long he
got a breaking ball on the first pitch
and launched it
curveball
and that ball
screamed out of here
up over the bullpen area first roll out
of the bullpen
that's a shot doogie fired up and taken
the ride
and that is three straight walks to load
them up for the marlins but adavino's
gonna get
doesn't seem too pleased that
this thing's still going and that he's
got to pitch through this cooper is
dodging puddles as he leads off third
dickerson and alfaro on as well in the
01 is caught on and miss nothing in two
one more
they yell anavino z02
he got him swinging
a strikeout for out of eno to leave him
low they got to bring the top out now
they've got to this field right now is
unplayable now the question is will
there be a let up in the rain at any
point tonight
not expect it to be no
and so we go into a rain delay here
in the sixth inning and they have called
it so officially over the red sox win
5-2